Nicht so richtig. Theoretische gibt es an der TU auch als Begriff, aber praktische so als Begriff nicht.
Was ist in theoretischer Informatik?
Ja, so Leute, die sich mit Problemen beschäftigen, wie dem Halteproblem und Dinge, grundsätzlich unendlich viel Speicher haben. Und man eigentlich auch eher mit Formeln auf dem Blatt Papier arbeitet, statt mit Code, um es plakativ auszudrücken. Also eigentlich eher angewandte Mathematik. Weil es mit Computern zu tun hat, also mit abstrakten Berechenbarkeiten.
Kann ein Computerprogramm entscheiden, ob ein anderes Computerprogramm anhält oder endlos weiterläuft und in eine Endlostreife kommt?
Also es geht um Informatik. Es kommt darauf an, was da ist.
Ist das ein Angebot?
Nein.
Also meistens Kaffee. In meinem Informatikstudium gab es einen kleinen Kaffee, das war so 0, 2 Liter Becher und einen großen Kaffee, das war 0, 5 Liter. Also Filterkaffe, wo man merkt.
Ich habe jetzt immer nicht genau verstanden, was theoretische Informatik macht.
Informatik, also erstmal grundsätzlich. Handelt es sich von der Geschichte her um einen Zweig der Mathematik, der sich damit beschäftigt hatte, ob man Mathematik so weit formalisieren kann, dass man sie automatisieren kann. Die Frage ist, kann ich sozusagen eine Vorschrift für jemanden angeben, der dann entscheiden kann, anhand dieser Vorschrift, in dem man sie nacheinander ausführt, ob etwas wahr oder falsch ist? Das ging also los im 19. Jahrhundert mit Russell und dem Versuch sozusagen, die gesamte Mathematik zu akzomatisieren und zu formalisieren. Und da sind sie auch drauf gekommen, was kann man denn ausrechnen, was kann man nicht ausrechnen? Gibt es da Unterschiede? Was ist Berechenbarkeit? Und da sind sie also zu Modellen von Berechenbarkeit gekommen. Und eins davon ist die bekannte Thüring-Maschine, die nicht das eleganteste Modell der Berechenbarkeit ist, aber den schönen Vorteil hat, dass man im Prinzip sowas Ähnliches auch bauen kann. Das ist ein Automat und der hat ein Band und da schreibt er Dinge drauf und dann guckt er auf das Band drauf und dann entscheidet er anhand seines Zustands, dem was da steht, ob er jetzt das Band nach links schiebt oder nach rechts schiebt oder was drauf schreibt oder so. Und das ist schon relativ nah an etwas dran, was man bauen kann. Man kann sich also so ein Ding vorstellen, wo man so ein Band reinsteckt, also um Berechenbarkeit im abstrakten Gengster. Und daraus hat sich die Informatik entwickelt, auch weil sie festgestellt haben, irgendwann, naja, das kann man ja bauen. Und dann haben sie solche Maschinen gebaut und dann waren wir dann plötzlich in der praktischen Informatik.
Also, warte mal, also theoretische Informatik ist die theoretische Wissenschaft davon, was man unter Umständen praktisch bauen könnte, aber nicht tut, weil es nicht praktikabel ist.
Ja, was im abstrakten Sinne berechenbar ist. Also was kannst du ausrechnen? Das ist die Frage, die sich da stellen.
Aber das ist ja sozusagen, das ist im Prinzip was, das ist sehr universitär.
Das ist sehr universitär und abstrakt. Da schreibst du auch heutzutage mehr, aber früher schrieb man da keine Programme, sondern Papers. Und dann im nächsten Schritt guckt man sich die Komplexität von Algorithmen an. Also wie schnell bist du denn fertig damit? Ist es überhaupt lohnt sich, überhaupt anzufangen zu rechnen, weil du irgendwann ein Ergebnis kriegst?
Aber das hört sich schon wieder sehr praktisch an, dass sie sagen, ich schreibe eine Software, damit ich natürlich auch wissen, wie schnell die ist.
Das kann praktische Anwendungen haben. Also wir hatten in der Firma mal den Fall, dass wir überlegt haben, ob wir eine Software jetzt optimieren. Das heißt, ob wir einen Programmierer eine Woche hinsetzen, um das Programm schneller zu machen, oder ob wir einfach das Programm laufen lassen, weil wir es eh nur zweimal laufen lassen. Und dann musste man halt ausrechnen, wie viel schneller kann man das Programm theoretisch kriegen, rentiert sich der Arbeitsaufwand von einer Woche oder lassen es einfach laufen, weil so oft wird es eh nicht laufen und wir müssen das noch einmal machen zum Importieren. Da ging es glaube ich darum, die Wikipedia zu importieren oder sowas.
Tatsächlich hat die theoretische Informatik auch praktische Relevanz, sonst würde man das ja nicht machen.
Du möchtest zum Beispiel, dass jemand beweist, dass der Code, der im Flugzeug läuft, nicht einfach so anhält.
Und das geht dann auch, ja?
Das ist verschieden gut. Die Art und Weise, wie Code für Flugzeuge geschrieben werden, ist ganz schön mühselig. Also die schreiben so was wie 100 Zeilen C-Code pro Monat pro Programmierer, weil der Aufwand so groß ist.
Das immer noch zu kontrollieren, dass das noch funktioniert?
Genau, genau. Das hat allerdings mittelmäßig, also zunehmend mehr mit theoretischer Informatik zu tun. Früher war das einfach alles manuelle Prüfungen und Dokumentation. Man hat also irgendwie 20 Zeilen Code geschrieben und dafür erst mal 100 Seiten Text mit Requirement, Analyse, Testing, Interaktion mit anderen Systemen, Impact-Analyse, Risiko-Analyse und so einen ganzen Quatsch gemacht. Und heutzutage kann man dann teilweise schon mal eine Software drüber laufen lassen, die sich die Software anguckt und sagt, die hat Eigenschaft XY.
Aber dann muss die Software, die da drüber läuft, natürlich auch bewiesen sein.
Da können wir mal eine eigene Sendung drüber machen.
Okay, gut. Vertiefen wir das nicht, aber halten wir fest, theoretische Informatik ist die arcane Magie. Kann man auch ohne theoretische Informatik Informatik studieren?
Ja, man kann dem größten Teil entgehen.
Also das geht schon. Es gibt halt Grundlagenvorlesungen, da muss man durch. Da lernt man auch Automatentheorie zum Beispiel. Das ist auch durchaus alles hilfreich, weil so eine Automat... Eine Automat braucht man, wenn man Netzwerkprotokoll implementieren möchte, so was wie TCP oder so. Da gibt es halt Zustände. Da ist so ein Verständnis für Automatentheorie schon sehr hilfreich, wenn man sowas mal selber machen möchte.
Aber Grundlagen und dann ist auch gut. Das geht schon.
Also ich hab zum Beispiel keinen einzigen Schein in theoretischer Informatik.
Du bist ja auch ganz komisch.
Also lustig finde ich... Also insbesondere das mit den TCP-Paketen und den Sprachen, das ist eine Geschichte, wo die theoretische Informatik und die praktische Informatik... Ich erklär's gleich, ich hol gleich mal aus. Aber es ist da, wo die Welten miteinander kollidieren, wo die Realität einfach nicht so ist, wie du das im Studium lernst. Also Sprachen, da gab es mal diesen Chomsky, den man hauptsächlich als Sprachwissenschaftler kennt. Mittlerweile gibt er auch öfter mal im Fernsehen seine Meinung zum politischen Weltgeschehen ab. Aber der hat zur Informatik auch was beigetragen, nämlich an der Systematisierung von Sprachen, von Computersprachen, sowas wie HTML oder Programmiersprachen. Und der hat da Hierarchien für aufgebaut. Und zu den Hierarchien der Sprachen gehören verschiedene Algorithmen, mit denen man diese Sprachen dann parsen kann, also sich auseinandernehmen, sich angucken kann und so. Und da gibt es also so grobe Unterscheidungen wie reguläre Ausdrücke, Regular Expressions, hat der ein oder andere schon mal gesehen, die man mit einem solchen Automaten lösen kann. Und dann gibt es Sachen, die zum Beispiel Klammern haben, wo für jede geöffnete Klammer auch hinten wieder eine Klammer zugemacht werden muss. Und da muss man sich irgendwo merken, wie viele Klammern aufgemacht werden, damit die auch alle wieder zugemacht werden können. Und das muss man irgendwo auf einen Stack tun. So einen Stapel haben, wo man sich das merkt und ablegt. So als grobe Hierarchie. Da denkst du irgendwie, toll, großartig, ich hab die Welt verstanden. Kommst du in den Praxis und stellst dann erstmal fest, dass die Perl-Regular-Expressions gar keine regulären Ausdrücke sind, sondern viel mächtiger und auch gar nicht.
Also ich habe verstanden, ich hab zwischendurch was verstanden, nämlich wenn man Programme schreibt, macht man viele Klammern, dann muss man darauf achten, dass man in den Klammern, die man aufgemacht hat, auch irgendwann wieder zu macht. Den Rest habe ich nicht verstanden.
Das sozusagen, das mit dem Klammern zählt, ist schon eine kompliziertere Sprache als, was ist eine Regular-Expression? Das ist sowas wie irgendwie, also alle Elemente meiner Sprache sind 3 As, gefolgt von 0 oder beliebig vielen Bs. Also A, A, A, B oder A, A, A, B, B sind alles Worte aus meiner Sprache. Definier ich so. Da musst du aber nicht zählen. Da kannst du irgendwie sagen, naja, wenn ich ein B gesehen habe, dann bin ich im Zustand, ich habe ein B gesehen. Wenn ich noch ein B sehe, bin ich wieder im Zustand, ich habe ein B gesehen. Da muss man sich nichts merken. Außer irgendwie, man ist gerade im Zustand, man hat ein B gesehen und nicht irgendwie mitzählen. Theoretische Informatik erzählt dir, für welche Sprachen du mitzählen musst und für welche nicht mitzählen musst. Und das macht dann was? Davon hängt ab, was du für einen Algorithmus brauchst, um die Sprache zu verstehen. Also ob du das einfach machen kannst oder ob das schwierig ist. Und am Ende des Tages hat das aber alles nichts mit der wirklichen Welt zu tun, weil in der Praxis wird alles komplett anders gemacht.
Ja, aber in der Praxis gibt es dann immer wieder Leute, die wollen dann HTML mit Regular Expressions wie SED, AWK oder so parsen und wundern sich, warum das dann nicht funktioniert.
Leute, was?
HTML ist halt sowas, da muss man sich Dinge merken. Und bei Regular Expressions geht das nicht so einfach. Also eigentlich gar nicht. Und deswegen, wenn man Komsky zugehört hat, weiß man, dass man mit einer regulären AWK niemand mit HTML parsen kann.
Okay, lass mich die Frage anders stellen. Wenn ich verstehen will, was ihr gerade geredet habt in den letzten 10 Minuten, muss ich dann theoretisch Informatik studiert haben?
Oder diesen Stackoverflow-Artikel dazu lesen. Im Prinzip ist das ein typischer Bestandteil Grundkurs theoretischer Informatik und auch einer, an dem man fast nicht vorbeikommt. Das ist so klassische Informatik 50er Jahre.
Ich entschuldige mich an dieser Stelle bei den Hörern und Hörerinnen, weil ich sozusagen nicht schaffe, das so aufzuklären, dass das, glaube ich, wirklich jeder versteht. Das wird so schwierig. Machen wir deswegen schnell weiter. Es gibt also theoretische Informatik. Bei mir war es praktische, hieß das. Da ging es um Datenbanken, wie man die macht, oder Compilerbau. Gibt es sowas als eigenes Kapitel?
Wir hatten damals nur diesen Compilerbau.
Ich glaube, es gab auch einzelne. Nicht als einzelner Paket praktischer Informatik. Es gab Datenbanksysteme, es gab Betriebssystempraktikungen, es gab ein Ding, wo man ein bestimmtes Netzwerk programmiert hat. Der ganze Netzwerk kam, das gab es aber als einzelner Block, aber nicht zusammengefasst unter dem Begriff.
Und was noch? Technische Informatik?
Technische Informatik ist ein eigener Studiengang bei uns, der die Elektrotechnik und die Informatik versucht, unter einen Hut zu bringen. Das heißt, man lernt aus beiden das Schlimmste, ich meine aus beiden das Beste. Was es seit ein paar Jahren erst gibt, ist an der TU zum Beispiel die Wirtschaftsinformatik, weil die TU gesagt hat, wir hätten gerne eine Wirtschaftsinformatik, die mehr technischen Fokus hat. An anderen Unis ist es so, dass man da mehr einen Wirtschaftsfokus hat und nebenbei noch ein bisschen Informatik lernt. Es gibt Bioinformatik, aber das sind alles einzelne Studiengänge.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie genau sind denn diese verheirateten Fachgänge zu verstehen? Ist es einfach, dass ich halbe halbe studiere?
Das kommt immer sehr drauf an.
Ich hasse diese juristischen Antworten, dass die Rechtsanwälte sagen, es kommt drauf an.
Es hat schon viele gemeinsame Grundlagen. Die ganze Grundlage der Programmierung und Mathematik und Informatik, das hörst du halt immer. Und in der Bioinformatik, dann hörst du auch ein bisschen Biologie mit. Und vieles ist dann halt eine Vorlesung oder irgendwie zwei, drei Vorlesungen über die Semester verteilt. Und dann war es das. Und die hören dann auch Leute aus verschiedenen Fachbereichen. Also so was wie Compilerbau war zum Beispiel zwei, drei Vorlesungen. Oder 3D-Grafik kann das sein, dass du noch mal zwei, drei Vorlesungen hast. Dann gibt es dann noch die Leute, die Spiele Design studieren, die machen dann auch noch die 3D-Grafik und kriegen nebenbei noch einen Kurs in, wie das eigentlich mit dieser Kunst funktioniert und Gestaltung und so und wie man Geschichte erzählt. Oder wie gesagt in der Bioinformatik, wie das mit der Zelle ist und der DNA und wie die Proteine gefaltet werden. Da hat man dann schon sozusagen Spezialisierung, wo man eine ganze Menge Informatik lernt, aber dann jeweils auch noch einen anderen Bereich dazu.
Ich denke, wir sollten erst mal kurz zerlegen, wie so ein Studium eigentlich generell aussieht. Und das ist, dass man eigentlich erst mal diesen Block hat, drei bis vier Jahre, je nachdem, wo man macht. Das ist ein Bachelor, was früher so irgendwie das Grundstudium war. Dann hat man noch mal so eine, na, ein bis zwei Jahre, je nachdem, wann und wo man irgendwie seinen Master macht dahinter. Master. Und dann hast du eben auch noch erwähnt, dann gibt es halt noch den PhD, also die Promotion dahinter. Und das können dann noch mal so vier, fünf, sechs Jahre, also fast genauso lang, wenn nicht sogar länger, als der ganze Block davor sein, bis man dann halt wirklich so ein Informatikstudium wirklich bis zum ultimativen Endboss durchgespielt hat.
Aber macht man Doktor auch, wenn man nicht im Wissenschaftsbetrieb bleiben will?
Also ich versuch das gerade zum Beispiel. Ich arbeite momentan an der Uni, aber ich werde, wenn ich dann irgendwann mal erfolgreich promoviert habe, nicht an der Uni bleiben. Weil dann bin ich auch zu alt.
Aber zurück zum ersten Schritt. Also es gibt das Bachelorstudium slash Grundstudium. Ist das dann für alle gleich? Also ist das quasi wie Schule nur an der Uni? Nee, auch schon nicht.
Also die Technikinformatiker an der TU zum Beispiel haben Vorlesungen aus der Informatik und aus der Elektrotechnik. Die ITM, IT im Maschinenbau oder sowas. Die haben komplett eigene Vorlesungen. Das ist dann zwar auch was mit starkem Informatikfokus, aber die haben eigentlich keine... Also die haben für sich alleine.
Ich hab Frage falsch gestellt. Ich meinte nicht sozusagen, ob die verschiedenen Studiengänge, die Informatik im Namen tragen, unterschiedlich sind, sondern wenn ich mich einschreibe für ein bestimmtes Studium und dann sozusagen das bis zum Bachelor bringe, machen dann alle Kommilitonen, die sich zum selben Zeitpunkt eingeschrieben haben, dasselbe wie ich? Oder finden da auch schon Spezialisierungen statt?
So 80 Prozent, es gibt aber Spezialisierungen. Also wir haben Studiengebiete, heißt das, glaube ich, an der TU, wo es zum Beispiel mehr Richtung Netzwerk gehen kann oder mehr Richtung Programmierung.
Aber 20 Prozent, das ist dann sozusagen so, dass da ein Häubchen oben drauf, eigentlich machen alle dasselbe?
Also vor allem der Punkt danach machen sie nicht alle dasselbe. Ja, also wenn die erstmal ihren Bachelor haben, dann können...
Genau, deswegen die Frage war erstmal bis zum Bachelor?
Wenn man in einem Studium gegangen ist, ist das relativ homogen.
Und ist es so, dass man mit dem Bachelor sozusagen auch schon aufhören kann? Oder ist der Master quasi... Also die Politik sagt ja.
Die Politik sagt ja, und das passt, glaube ich, auch.
Nee, ich möchte aber von euch... Also auch wenn es albern, klingt die Praxis besser.
In der Praxis wird man glaube ich nicht so richtig glücklich.
In der Praxis heißt es immer Hochschulabschluss erwünscht oder gleichartige Qualifikation der Berufserfahrung.
Aber ist Bachelor dann schon quasi...
Es kommt drauf an, wo im öffentlichen Dienst nicht, ja. Aber wenn du dich bei einer Firma bewirbst, ist es echt so, dass die... ob du studiert hast und was du studiert hast, schon so ein bisschen nachrangig ist. Sondern irgendwie, wenn du zeigen kannst, naja, ich hab halt hier fünf Jahre bei der Firma XY Projekt Z geleitet, was am besten auch noch bekannt ist, und kann das und das und das und das, dann wirst du im Interview getestet, ob du das und das und das wirklich kannst und dann wirst du angestellt.
Okay, also sagen, es ist relativ wahrscheinlich, wenn ich an der Uni bin und nicht mein Studium sowieso irgendwie in den Wind schießen will, dass ich dann auch noch Master hinterher mache. Wie sieht der aus? Der ist dann spezialisierter? Oder ist das auch so ganz klar reglementiert, was da passiert? Sollte der Schwierigkeitsgrad nicht ansteigen?
Der Bachelor vermittelt die ganzen Grundlagen. Das heißt, du musst dich durch diesen ganzen Kram durchquälen, der dich eigentlich gar nicht so richtig interessiert. Und auch durch diese Mathe-Vorlesung. Und meine Erfahrung, ich hab Diplom studiert, war, dass dann im Hauptstudium plötzlich alles total einfach wurde. Weil ich konnte mich plötzlich auf die Sachen konzentrieren, die mich wirklich interessiert haben, die ich spannend fand. Und das fällt einem dann natürlich unendlich viel leichter, wenn man auch viel leichter oder viel lieber sich mit den Sachen beschäftigt.
Außerdem sind die Grundstudiumsveranstaltungen, also bei uns damals, als es noch Grundstudium hieß, die waren immer Montag morgens um 8. Und die Hauptstudiumsveranstaltung, also was heute Master ist, das ist dann immer so gegen Nachmittag gewesen.
Das kommt auch dazu, ja.
Sehr, sehr gut. So, und dann bin ich aber fertig mit dem Hochschulstudium, wenn ich will. Kann aber auch noch promovieren. Jetzt finde ich das ganz lustig, weil mir gerade auffällt, ich kenne mittlerweile genug Leute, die das versucht haben und auch fertig gemacht haben, deswegen weiß ich, wie das geht. Aber könntest du mal für Menschen, die vielleicht gerade am Anfang stehen und sich überlegen, wäre das was für mich, was genau ist das eigentlich, dieses Promovieren? Wie mache ich das? Okay, wenn ihr diese Blicke jetzt gesehen hättet, dann wüsstet ihr, dass die eigentliche Antwort auf die Frage ist, man macht es nicht.
Vier Jahre Schmerz. Was ist einfach zu beantworten? Ein Armutsrisiko. Also das ist unheimlich zeitraubend, weil man tatsächlich selbstständig wissenschaftlich arbeitet und hinterher ein Werk rausbringen muss, was sozusagen etwas Neues schafft. Die Theorie ist, wenn du deine Bachelorarbeit schreibst, dann musst du im Wesentlichen beweisen, dass du gut darin bist, Bücher zu lesen, das Gelesene wiederzugeben. Bei einer Masterarbeit ist es schon so ein bisschen, naja, mal auch was Eigenes bauen, aber jetzt schon unter Anleitung auf den existieren Gebieten. So ein PhD, so ein Doktorabschluss, da ist die Anforderung, dass du etwas Neues selbst tätig schaffst. Und das ist in der Regel sehr umfangreich. Dich leitet auch keiner an. Du hast vielleicht einen Doktorvater, mit dem du dich mal austauschen kannst.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, mal ganz praktisch zu sagen, also eine Masterarbeit ist, glaube ich, um die 80 Seiten. Was ist deine Doktorarbeit in der Vergiltnis und wie lange habe ich dafür Zeit und was mache ich währenddessen?
Es gibt jetzt nur von fünf Seiten, aber die sind sehr selten.
In der Regel doppelt so lange wie so eine Masterarbeit. Aber auch schon mit einem höheren Anspruch. Das ist, glaube ich, das Problem dabei. Im Anspruch selber scheitern auch viele Leute. Du brauchst erstens die Disziplin, kontinuierlich daran zu arbeiten, ohne dass jemand irgendwie alle drei Tage dasteht und fragt, hast du schon wieder eine Seite geschrieben. Die gesamte Literaturrecherche zu machen, das so zu dokumentieren, dass du es hinterher wieder findest. Dann stellst du mittendrin fest, dass die Theorie, von der du ausgegangen bist, auf die du deine Arbeit aufbaust, eigentlich völliger Blödsinn ist. Dann kommt noch mal was Neues raus. Oder, keine Ahnung, dir wird langweilig, weil du schon Ewigkeiten in diesem Thema kaust. Das sind so die typischen Probleme, die an dir treffen.
Plus noch dieser ganze Verwaltungskram. Wenn du an einer großen Universität bist, mit starken Sparauflagen, wie der TU Berlin, dann hast du plötzlich 800, 900 Studenten, die du betreuen musst mit drei Leuten. Du musst halt noch nebenbei diese ganze Lehre organisieren und hast noch eine ganze Reihe anderer Aufgaben, parallel zu deiner eigentlichen Promotion.
Ich schreibe eine Doktorarbeit gleichbedeutend mit. Ich bin an einer Uni angestellt und auch für die Lehre zuständig.
Nicht unbedingt, aber das ist sehr üblich. Du musst ja von irgendwas leben in der Zeit. Deswegen sage ich, es handelt sich um ein Armutsrisiko. Der übliche Weg ist, dass du an einer Uni als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter angestellt bist. Das ist ganz unglaublich schlecht bezahlt, wie überhaupt alle akademischen Jobs in Deutschland unglaublich schlicht bezahlt sind.
Da würde ich jetzt mal, vor allem beim Berliner IT-Stellenmarkt, ganz stark widersprechen.
An einer Uni stellen?
Ich muss feststellen, dass die vier Jahre, die ich jetzt mit promovieren verbracht habe, ich durchgehend mehr Geld als meine Partnerin auch in der IT-Führungsposition auch einen Master verdient habe. Aber nicht an einer Uni? Ich war an der TU Berlin.
Ach so, was ist denn TU Berlin?
TVL 13.
Was heißt das?
Das heißt, dass ich aktuell TVL 13 Stufe 3, also mit jetzt vier Jahren an der Uni, mit gut 50.000 Brutteln nach Hause gehe.
Als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter? Wie viele Leute musstest du in den Rücken stechen, um an diese Stelle zu kommen?
Keinen. Der Vorteil des Informatikers ist, dass er in der Regel auch volle Stellen kriegt an der Uni, wenn er möchte. Archäologen bekommen eine 16. Stelle, damit sie versichert sind, wenn sie im Labor arbeiten.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. Informatikstunden bist du ja gerade sehr beliebt. Ist es trotzdem so, dass an der Uni Fachkräftemangel was die Mitarbeiter angeht, ist?
Es gibt halt keine Stellen, weil gespart werden muss. Aber wenn du gut bist und einen Doktorvater, eine Doktermutter findest, die meint, dass du promotionswürdig bist und dich einstellt, dann hast du einen sicheren Job die nächsten Jahre.
Okay, aber es ist schon so, dass auch das, also auf eine Stelle wollen dann 100 Leute und ihr beiden selbst sein, die die Glück gehabt haben.
Den Eindruck hab ich jetzt eher nicht so, nee. Weil du verdienst halt nicht so viel wie in einer freien Wirtschaft, wenn du halbwegs geschickt dich anstellst.
Moment, ich nehme einen Widerspruch.
Und halt bereit bist auch nicht in Berlin zu bleiben zum Beispiel.
Wie lange dauert so eine Doktorarbeit?
Offiziell drei Jahre.
Wie lange schreibt ihr beiden schon?
Vier, knapp.
Ich hab das Ding nach drei Jahren und neun Monaten Roundabout abgegeben.
Okay, das heißt du bist jetzt Doktor?
Nee, noch nicht ganz. Ich muss noch den Endboss der Berliner Verwaltung besiegen.
Was heißt das? Ist das nur eine Formsache? Also den grünen Passierschein A2?
Erstens sind die Formulare bei uns an der Uni blau und gelb, um Scheine zu kriegen. Und die müssen mit Durchschlag gemacht werden. Und es ist in der Tat ein PDF-Format, das muss noch veröffentlicht werden. Da müssen noch so ein paar grüne Passierscheine ausgestellt werden.
Aber du musst jetzt nicht noch irgendwie einen Vortrag halten?
Das hat er schon gemacht. Das hab ich inzwischen hinter mir. Aber es ist jetzt noch wirklich der Verwaltungsboss.
Was passiert als nächstes? Also wenn der gelegt ist?
Wenn der gelegt ist, ganz ehrlich, ich fliege aus diesem Land und aus diesem Unisystem. Weil? Weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass universitäre Lehre, so wie ich sie bisher, zumindest im Rahmen meiner Promotion erleben durfte, nicht unbedingt das System ist, in dem ich forschen und lernen möchte.
Aber du möchtest forschen und lernen, gehst deswegen an ein anderes Land, an ein anderes Unisystem? Davon fragen, wohin?
Ich geh in die Niederlande.
Weil die da was anders machen?
Weil sie da mehr grundständiges Funding für die Lehre bieten und weil sie da eine Perspektive auf Lehre haben, wo sie einfach Lehre machen wollen und Menschen, unabhängig davon, wo sie gerade sind, versuchen, mit Wissen auszustatten, Wissen so zu dokumentieren, dass Leute das nutzen können, ob sie jetzt nur mal an der Uni sind oder nicht.
Das heißt, in Deutschland wird Lehre ab und zu empfunden, als, oh Gott, wir müssen das auch noch machen. Und da ist das wirklich Lebenszweck.
Das ist halt unterfinanziert. Auch wenn du gute Lehre machen möchtest, musst du halt woanders Abstriche machen. Also entweder ich mache gute Lehre, oder ich schreibe ein Paper, damit ich irgendwann mal eine Promotion schreiben kann.
Würdet ihr denn auch sagen, vielleicht im Ausland studieren, ist eine gute Idee?
Ja, definitiv.
Es gibt schon sehr namhafte Unis, die sich nicht in Deutschland befinden.
Wohin sollte man gehen?
Also University of Michigan ist sehr gut. Wenn man MMIT oder einen Stanfordenplatz kriegt, das sind gute Unis. Inria in Frankreich, Cambridge, alles namhafte Orte.
Das sind die klassischen großen Namen, die man im Kontext haben kann.
Ich möchte in dem Kontext meine Alma mater vorne heben. Es gibt die Universität von Amsterdam. Die hatten ein Studienprogramm, das heißt Network Engineering. Es ist massiv angewandt. Gleichzeitig aber trotzdem in universitärer Maße, mit dem man am Ende auch promovieren gehen kann. Nein, Tannenbaum ist an der VU, einer Freien Universität. In der Tat hatten wir noch einen Kurs an der Freien Universität, gehen aber auch bei einem Kollegen von Tannenbaum.
Jetzt musst du doch kurz erklären, wer Tannenbaum ist.
Tannenbaum ist einer der großen Menschen von Betriebssystembau.
Das ist der, der als dieser Linus damals mit dem Linux angefangen hat, ihm erzählt hat, mit dem Systemdesign hätte ich dich bei mir durchfallen lassen.
Okay, gut, also die großen Namen. In die Niederlande könnte man gehen. Noch was?
KU Leuven ist auch eine sehr gute Uni, auch in den Niederlanden.
Okay, in den Niederlanden haben wir noch was? Also noch ein Land sozusagen?
Jedes, wo man sich wohlfühlt.
Na ja, außer Deutschland, weil da ist ja... Oder ist das universitäre System so schlimm, dass man sagt, geht überall hin, nur nicht in Deutschland?
Also geht auf jeden Fall nicht an eine große Uni, würde ich sagen. Weil an einer großen Uni bist du verloren. Da kümmert sich niemand um dich, wenn es dir schlecht geht oder wenn du nicht mitkommst.
Seht ihr die Behörerinnen und Hörer? Vor zwei Stunden ungefähr habe ich gefragt, an welche Uni man gehen soll. Ich sage, es ist egal, in Deutschland kann man überall hingehen. Mittlerweile betreiben wir Landflucht und sagen, wenn ihr schon in Deutschland bleibt, dann lieber nicht an eine große Uni.
Die Frage am Anfang war aber, welche Uni in Deutschland?
Naja, aber selbst da hieß es sozusagen, es ist egal.
Dann sind die alle gar schlimm.
Na gut, wir werden sozusagen in der letzten halben Stunde noch mal genauer versuchen zu erklären, welche Ausbildungsform vielleicht die beste ist. Vorher gibt es noch ein ganz, ganz kleines Stück Musik.
Providers kritisieren geplante Breitbandmessung. Klaus Landefeld vom Eco-Verband der Internetwirtschaft kritisierte bei Heise Online die von der Bundesnetzagentur angestrebte neue Breitbandmessung per Applikation. Bei der bisherigen browserbasierten Breitbandmessung sei es nicht auf die Qualität eines einzelnen Anschlusses angekommen. Künftig sollten die Ergebnisse aber im Zweifelsfall vor Gericht als Beweis gelten. Daraus ergäben sich sehr hohe Anforderungen an das Analyseinstrument. Diese können nur erfüllt werden, wenn das entsprechende Werkzeug auf dem Breitbandrouter installiert würde. Links unten unbewaffnet. Beim Vorgehen gegen vermeintliche Betreiberinnen und Betreiber von Indymedia links unten wurden keine gefährlichen Gegenstände bei den Verdächtigen gefunden. Dies teilte das Bundesinnenministerium auf Nachfrage von netzpolitik.org mit. Der Bundesinnenminister Thomas de Maizière hatte auf einer Pressekonferenz am Morgen der Durchsuchung behauptet, bei den Betroffenen seien Waffen beschlagnahmt worden. ZITES Eröffnung abgesagt. ZITES hatte schon im Mai die Arbeit aufgenommen. Gestern sollte die zentrale Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich offiziell eröffnet werden. Die Feier wurde aber kurzfristig abgesagt. Als Grund wurde angegeben, dass Innenminister de Maizière aus Termingründen nicht kommen konnte. Es wird spekuliert, dass der eigentliche Grund der Absage die Tatsache ist, dass von den für dieses Jahr vorgesehenen 120 Planstellen bislang gerade einmal 17 besetzt werden konnten.
Wisst ihr woran das liegt? Die sind alle bei der Cyberfeuerwehr. So, das waren die Nerd-News, geschrieben von Mo, präsentiert von Helena. Vorher gab es noch die Musik von Stein van Waageren. Circe, hieß der Track, die auf dem Sofa wurde schon gebotert. Die Songs würden sich alle gleich anhören. Es ist halt ein Ambient-Album. Es ist halt so ruhig und entspannt. Ich lege meine Hand dafür ins Feuer, dass es drei unterschiedliche Tracks waren. Links zu allem auf chaosradio.ccc.de am Montag.
In der Pause gab es Kritik.
Woran?
Ich soll nicht sagen, dass jede große Uni scheiße ist.
Ach so, die Kamera ist ja nicht sehr doof. Können wir kurz die Kamera zuhalten? Wir haben viele Leute auf dem Sofa. Jetzt bitte mal die Hand heben. Wer diese Kritik sozusagen, also wer nicht daran glaubt, dass alle großen Unis doof sind? Bitte mal Hand heben. Also alle großen Unis sind doof, stimmt das? Ja, dann die Hand heben.
Du hast die Frage umgedreht.
Ja, ich hab die Frage umgedreht, aber anscheinend hat sie vorher. Gut, danke, vielen Dank. Also ich sag jetzt mal so, also Freunde haben mir erzählt, also alle großen Unis sind doof. Warum kritisiert man das? Weil man selber an einer großen Uni so ein Stockholm-Syndrom hat, oder?
Also ich kenne halt die Nachteile einer großen Uni und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es an einer kleinen Uni anders ist. Hab aber selber eine kleine Uni nie erlebt, persönlich.
Aber da haben wir doch hier jemanden, der eine kleine Uni erlebt hat.
Ja, und auch eine kleine Uni kann sich diese großen Probleme ziehen. Also das ist so ein ganz klassisches Problem, was Studieren extrem scheiße macht. Zentralisiertes Prüfungsamt. Einfach dieses, wir haben jetzt unsere 26.000 Studierenden und wir haben jetzt ein Prüfungsamt. Da sitzen dann 100 Sachbearbeitende drin. Also zwischen Anspruch und Realität. Und für die ist halt jede studierende Person gleich. Ob das jetzt irgendwie Philosophie, Informatik, das ist halt so ein Sachvorgang, der muss bearbeitet werden. Und es wird extrem viel angenehmer, wenn man ein studienfachbezogenes Prüfungsamt hat, wo Menschen sitzen, für die man wirklich ein Mensch ist und die sich mit Problemen von einzelnen Menschen auseinandersetzen können. Wenn dann mal irgendwie ein Schein zu spät kommt, um gerade diese 50 ECTS, die man nach den ersten ein, zwei Semestern haben muss, zu kriegen. Wenn sie sich halt verspätet unter wirklich Menschen sitzen und sagen so, okay, ja, ich hau jetzt unserem Institutsleiter nochmal auf die Finger, dass der Schein jetzt auch mal wirklich, wirklich, wirklich kommen muss. So, das ist was vollkommen anderes, als wenn da jemand sitzt so, ja, das haben mir heute schon 20 Leute erzählt, ist mir egal. Man hat bei so einer kleinen Uni mehr Chancen, sondern nicht zentralisiertes Prüfungsamt zu haben.
Und du hast vielleicht auch nicht 23 verschiedene Studienprogramme, wie Leute sich für irgendeine Vorlesung registrieren.
Ist es auch von Vorteil, in einer kleinen Stadt zu studieren, weil da nicht so viele Studenten hinkommen, also quasi die Uni auch nicht dann so aus allen Nähten platzt?
Actually, kleine Städte neigen dazu, wirklich sehr Studierenden dominiert zu sein. Vor allem so diese kleinen Unis, die ich kenne, so Münster aus Naabrück, die Städte haben so einen richtig dicken Studierendenstempel. Da merkt man mehr, dass da Studierende sind als hier in Berlin.
Das kann ja sein, aber das kann ja trotzdem bedeuten, dass nicht die Klassenräuber, ich bin nicht, aber die Jahrgänge sozusagen total überfüllt sind.
Ich würde mir schon denken, dass die vielleicht kleiner sind, weil die Kapazitäten auch gar nicht so groß sind. Wenn ich mir angucke, wir an der TU haben eine Erstsemester-Vorlesung, da registrieren sich halt 950 Studierende. Und dann sitzen da halt 900 Leute, das wird dann sehr schnell weniger. Aber am Ende vom Semester sind immer noch 720 davon übrig. Und du sitzt halt mit 720 Leuten im Hörsaal.
Die haben wie viele Betreuer?
Also theoretisch sollten 20 Personen im Turm sitzen, praktisch sind es 40. Und es gibt halt vier WM, die das dann irgendwie versuchen müssen zu betreuen. Also sagen wir mal so, fünf Leute machen es, zwei werden bezahlt. Weil du hast halt nur für zwei Leute die Stellen, die das machen. Und wenn du ein sehr engagiertes Fachgebiet bist, dann machen halt alle damit. Und wenn du ein Fachgebiet hast, das sowieso wenig Ressourcen hat, dann sind halt da zwei Leute und dann gibt es halt Vorlesungen aus der Konserve und es wird irgendwie mit minimal Effort dafür gesorgt, dass das halbwegs geht. Aber da ist halt keine persönliche Betreuung drin.
Um Gottes Willen. So ich würde jetzt mal hier in das Publikum gucken wollen. Liebes Publikum, wer von euch hat Informatik studiert oder hat vor Informatik zu studieren? Bitte mal die Hand heben. Das sind bitte oben lassen. Sehr schön. Wer wird es nochmal genau so entscheiden? Das sieht nicht so gut aus für das Informatikstudium.
Ganz kurz, aus Gründen, weil das Studium von der Organisation her oder wie es war blöd war, weil die Inhalte doof waren.
Das ist nichts, was man durch Handzeichen beantworten kann. Zum Abschluss der Sendung ist es gefuchtet.
Können wir da nicht nochmal einen positiven Aspekt reinbringen?
Ja, bitte.
Man muss auch sagen, ein Studienabschluss an einer großen Universität ist ein Signal für einen potenziellen Arbeitgeber, dass man in der Lage ist, mit einer wirren, komplexen, starren Bürokratie umzugehen.
Aber dazu müsste der Arbeitgeber dieses Chaosradio gehört haben. Moment, also tatsächlich ist diese Sendung eine Sendung voller Widerspruch. Ich höre erst irgendwie, es ist egal, in welche Uni man geht. Also Abschluss machen ist sowieso völlig überbewertet. Die Arbeitgeber wollen sowieso nicht irgendwie sehen, welchen Schein du hast, sondern die wollen wissen, wo dein GitHub-Account ist. Und jetzt höre ich dann wieder so, naja, es gibt schon gute Unis. Und der Arbeitgeber ist ja auch, wenn man da durchkommt an die große Stadt, dann weiß der Arbeitgeber auch, dass man sich durchbeißen kann.
Das ist immer die Frage, was willst du signalisieren, wo willst du hin im Leben? Willst du fröhlich vor dich hin einen Code schreiben? Oder hast du Aspiration, irgendwann mal als CTO im Vorstand zu sitzen?
Ähm, so, wir bauen das jetzt eine Reihe nach nochmal. Ich will was mit Computern machen. Soll ich Informatik studieren? Ja oder nein? Und wenn ja, warum nicht? Wir haben am Anfang der Sendung gefragt, warum habt ihr Informatik studiert? Die Antwort war in Abweichung immer so, ich wollte was mit Computern machen.
Um was mit Computern zu machen, brauchst du kein Studium. Aber wenn du was mit Computern machst, dann ermöglicht dir ein Studium Dinge, die ohne nicht gehen. Du kannst irgendwie problemlos glücklich werden mit Programmieren. Du kannst den ganzen Tag an tollen Projekten arbeiten und in Ruby irgendwelche Backends für Apps programmieren und die Apps selber ohne irgendwas damit zu tun zu haben, was in der Informatik schon vermittelt wird. Aber es gibt Spezialisierungen, die von der Informatik hilft. Wenn du irgendwie im Compilerbau landen willst oder in 3D-Grafik, weil dir einfach abgefahrener Frickelkram Spaß macht, den man sonst nirgendwo lernt. Oder wenn du halt Aspirationen hast, in der Firma auch mal ein bisschen aufzusteigen, ins Management zu gehen, vielleicht auch ins Upper Management. Da ist das quasi so ein Schein, wo dir bescheinigt wird, du bist in der Lage, unter widrigen Bedingungen Dinge zu erreichen. Da geht es nicht um die Inhalte, da geht es um, du hast dich da durchgekämpft.
Das ist aber nicht die Eintrittskarte, sondern das ist nur die Zugangsberechtigung für die Lotterie.
Genau.
So ein Studium kann natürlich auch schaden.
Leute!
Das muss gesagt werden. Es kann halt passieren, dass du überqualifiziert bist. Wenn du dann fröhlich vor dich hin promoviert hast, wirst du halt nicht mehr so eine normal, nicht so super bezahlte Coda-Stelle kriegen. Weil du halt möglicherweise nicht mehr als einfacher Programmierer angestellt wirst. Weil die Firma der Meinung ist, der es promoviert, den können wir nicht so bezahlen oder so. Das kann halt passieren, dass du plötzlich auch in die Schiene Management gedrückt wirst, weil du bist doch promoviert, du kannst das doch, obwohl du da gar nicht hin möchtest.
David, würdest du jetzt noch mal studieren wollen?
Ich hab damals mein Abitur abgebrochen, weil ich eh nicht studieren wollte.
Aber mit einer Ausbildung kann man studieren. Mit Ausbildung und Berufserfahrung kann man möglicherweise die Hochschulzugangsberechtigung nachweisen. Da gibt es irgendwelche wirren Wege.
Ich glaube, da muss man noch mal ein Jahr irgendwie einen anderen Bildungsweg ranhängen oder so. Es ist nicht so einfach.
Das ist relativ einfach. Die Fachhochschulzugangsberechtigung, die kriegst du auf jeden Fall mit so einem Physi zusammen und dann machst du deinen Bachelor-FH. Machst dann gerne noch mal einen Master-FH. Mit dem Master-FH kannst du in Deutschland inzwischen auch wunderbar promovieren. Also, es geht auf jeden Fall.
Wir machen nachher noch ein bisschen Studienbeschreibung.
Ob du willst oder nicht. Die Frage, die ich noch stelle, ist, sollte man direkt am Anfang studieren, also quasi, ich mache Abi, ich habe Computer bis jetzt schon toll gefunden, und jetzt will ich in dem Bereich arbeiten. Soll ich da studieren? Oder ist es vielleicht tatsächlich die bessere Wahl, auch zu sagen, okay, ich mache mal vielleicht, also nicht mal eine Ausbildung, sondern ich arbeite einfach mal in dem Bereich und bringe mir selber Sachen bei und hole es dann später nach. Oder, das ist eigentlich die eigentliche Frage, wird das Informatikstudium umso frustrierender, je mehr ich schon weiß?
Ja, also das Problem ist auch, je länger du aus der Schule weg bist, umso schwieriger wird es dir fallen, dich hinzusetzen und wieder Sachen zu lernen. Das geht halt einfacher, wenn man da nicht so lange raus ist und einfach weitermachen kann.
Ich muss ja vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen ein Gegenmodell erzählen. Also mein Betriebswirtschaftsstudium, das war ein Studium an einer privaten Hochschule neben der Arbeit, wo der Arbeitgeber dazu beigetragen hat, dass ich Studium machen konnte. Und das war so völlig anders als an einer öffentlichen Hochschule zu studieren. Weil die Leute, die kamen aus der Praxis, die haben also alle 20 Jahre Berufserfahrung, denen hast du keinen Scheiß mehr erzählt. Die Blocksignale waren freitags und samstags. Das heißt, das was an der Uni über einen Semester geht mit jeweils Vorlesungen, wurde dir so am Stück von Freitag bis Samstag reingedrückt. Dann hast du hinterher den Vorlesenden bewertet und wenn er keine 1 gekriegt hat, wurde das Honorarium 20% gekürzt. Das sind unglaubliche Zustände. Dann bist nicht du dem Prüfungsamt hinterhergelaufen, sondern das Prüfungsamt ist dir. Da sind wir so, Herr Brug, Sie studieren jetzt schon 3 Jahre, wollen Sie nicht mal langsam? Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Zeit und so. Na ja, da können wir was einrichten, wir schicken Ihnen mal eine Verlängerung. Wann haben Sie Zeit für eine Prüfung? Am Ende des Tages hat mich das auch nicht mehr gekostet als an einer Uni mit Studiengebühren, die es ja immer noch gibt in Deutschland. Es kann ganz anders sein.
Was mir gerade auch auffällt ist, das wollte ich vorhin noch gefragt haben, diese Kombinationsinformatiken. Im Journalismus kenne ich ja so, es gibt ja Journalisten, die machen halt eine Ausbildung, also mit Volontariat und so was, und die arbeiten dann als Allrounder. Oder spezialisieren sich dann später, weil sie ein besonderes Thema haben. Oder, so wie ich, man studiert halt was ordentliches, also wait, nee, nach dieser Sendung kann ich das auch nicht mehr sagen, aber man studiert halt sozusagen eine Fachrichtung und bringt den Journalismus sozusagen selber bei. Und wird dann Fachjournalist in dem Sinne. Ist das bei der Informatik möglicherweise auch der bessere Weg oder ein anderer gangbarer Weg, dass man sagt, ich studiere nicht Bioinformatik, sondern ich studiere Biologie und helfe mir dann nebenbei noch das Programmieren auf, weil das eh das Wichtige ist? Skeptische Gesichter, Stirnrunzeln.
Da ist es befürchtet, teilweise zu spitz hier, oder?
Also zur Bioinformatik habe ich auch noch eine lustige Anekdote. Nämlich, dass irgendjemand, der früh mit dabei war von der Biologie-Seite, sich mit den Informatikern unterhalten hat und dann mal so erklärt hat, was er davon wollte. Und dann kamen die theoretischen Informatikern und sagten, okay, dein Problem ist NP-vollständig. Und dann sind sie wieder weggelaufen. Das heißt sozusagen, wir haben bewiesen, dass es theoretisch ein schweres Problem ist.
Okay, und dann hat er beschlossen, selber Informatik zu lernen, weil ihm dann nicht geholfen wurde.
Genau, und wie das immer so ist, natürlich gibt es sozusagen, die 100%-Lösung ist sozusagen so schwer, dass man sie nicht erreichen kann. Aber mit 99% der Lösung ist es in der Regel getan. Und man kann es auch machen, man kann auch medialistisch studieren und dann hinterher in die Programmierung gehen. Das ist auch gar kein Problem.
Okay, so, dann zum Abschluss noch, weil ich glaube, wir haben das Thema Schöpfen behandelt. Oder gibt es noch einen wichtigen Punkt, der euch auf der Seele brennt?
Wir sollten noch ein paar Minuten rein investieren, um zu sagen, dass alles nicht wirklich so dunkel ist, wie es gerade hier aussieht. Es ist durchaus positiv informativ studiert.
Jetzt entscheidet euch doch mal!
Es hat richtig Spaß gemacht.
Dass ihr in Stockholm studiert, ne? Wir gehen noch einmal das Sofa entlang und on a lighter note könnt ihr noch mal sagen, was das Schöne am Informatikstudium oder der Ausbildung war und was ihr euch vielleicht für die Zukunft wünscht und den Menschen, die dir überlegen, Informatik zu studieren, mit auf den Weg gehen wollt. Tobias, du hast ja gerade gesagt, noch ein paar Minuten kriegt man voll mit den schönen Dingen.
Das schöne Ding ist auf jeden Fall, dass man eine Möglichkeit hat, sich zu entfalten. Dass man überhaupt dieses generelle Studierending hat. Mutags hat so schön gesagt, man hat eigentlich es leichter, direkt nach der Schule morgens um 18 Uhr in der Vorlesung zu sitzen. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, in meinen ersten Semestern saß ich nie, also nicht ganz nie, aber die Male, wo ich morgens um 18 Uhr in der Vorlesung saß, war ich betrunken und gerade aus der örtlichen Studentenknappe nach Hause gekommen, auf dem Weg nach Hause, zu Kommilitonen begegnet und dann in diesem Vorlesungssaal geendet. Also man kann da schon eine ganze Menge über sich selber, wie man arbeitet und generell über die Welt lernen und sich sehr entwickeln. Das sagt einigen Leuten zu, das sagt anderen Leuten total nicht zu und die kommen damit echt nicht klar. Aber ausprobieren.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich schreibe mich jetzt ein, ich gebe mir mal ein Jahr, um zu gucken. Ist das verschwendete Lebenszeit, wenn man sich dann entscheidet? Oder ist das so was, wo du sagst, das kann man auf jeden Fall mal machen?
Ich würde definitiv sagen, lieber ausprobieren als nicht ausprobieren.
Ausprobieren und auch an den Unis gibt es eigentlich überall irgendwelche Studenten, Initiativen, die sich da irgendwie engagieren, das Studium besser zu machen oder so. Und mit den Leuten kann man auch als Schüler reden und die fragen, wie ist das eigentlich bei euch? Was macht ihr hier eigentlich? Was ist spannend? Und normalerweise kriegt man da schon eine ganze Menge raus. Und das Schöne an Informatik ist eben, dass die Themengebiete so groß sind und es so viele verschiedene gibt, dass eigentlich für jeden was dabei ist. Also wenn man irgendwas mit Computern machen möchte, findet man da auf jeden Fall irgendwo so eine Ecke, in der man sich wohlfühlen kann und richtig Spaß haben kann. Und man kann halt Leuten helfen, Probleme zu lösen da draußen.
Ich hab mich mit der Frage beschäftigt, wem würde ich einer Ausbildung empfehlen und wem nicht. Ist gar nicht so einfach. Also ihr da draußen, wenn ihr euch schon lange mit so IT-Dingen beschäftigt und auch Leute kennt, meine Eltern werden jetzt wahrscheinlich von der Couch aufspringen und schreien, oh nein, nicht so unvernünftig, aber ich kenne genug Fälle in meinem Freundeskreis, wo es super funktioniert hat, dass sie ohne Ausbildung das machen, was sie können und wollen, was ihnen Spaß macht und sich damit auch unglaublich gut selber weiterbilden konnten. Da bleibt die Frage, für wen ist die Ausbildung jetzt richtig. Also natürlich für alle, die Drucker anschließen wollen sowieso, für alle, die Windows Domain administrieren wollen wahrscheinlich auch. Wenn ihr mehr wollt, kann die Ausbildung richtig sein, aber dann müsst ihr euch damit abfinden, dass die Berufsschule öde sein wird. Und kleiner Appell an alle Unternehmen und Personalabteilungen da draußen. Da draußen bezahlt eure Auszubildenden richtig. Nur weil alle machen, ist es noch lange nicht richtig. Also nur weil alle ihre Auszubildenden schlecht bezahlen, ist es noch lange nicht nicht scheiße. Und genau das ist so mein Appell.
Andreas noch?
Ja, ich würde sagen, ich würde studieren, allen Leuten empfehlen, die Spaß daran haben, sich einen Knoten ins Gehirn zu machen, ohne notwendigerweise sich die Frage dabei zu stellen, wofür das denn überhaupt gut sei. Es ist was für Leute mit Spaß am Denken, und je mehr man Spaß am Denken hat, desto mehr Spaß hat man beim Studium, und zwar ganz egal, was man studiert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das das letzte Wort ist, aber es ist einfach so. Gut, dann vielen Dank, Andreas, David, Mutax und Tobias. Viel Spaß euch noch in eurem Informatikerleben. Liebes Publikum, gibt es hier noch Fragen oder Anmerkungen?
Habt ihr praktische Erfahrungen oder Erfahrungen von Bekannten von euch, die jetzt weder eine Uni noch eine Ausbildung, sondern z.B. eine FH oder eine BA gemacht haben?
Was ist eine BA?
Berufsakademie, das ist was, was es glaube ich nur in Baden-Württemberg gibt. So ein bisschen fachhochschulmäßig, noch ein bisschen verschulte als Fachhochschule. Was aber bei Unternehmen da wohl sehr beliebt ist. Weil mir das so ein bisschen jetzt als Zwischenkontrast gefehlt hat. Weil ich den Eindruck hatte, dass viele Kommitonen, ich hab an der FH studiert, sehr begeistert waren, dass sie die FH quasi als Upgrade auf einer Ausbildung gemacht haben. Weil ihnen die Ausbildung nicht genug war und sie gesagt haben, okay, eigentlich kitzelt mich das intellektuell jetzt ein bisschen mehr zu machen. Ich möchte aber Praktiker bleiben und für die hat sich dann die FH als sehr lohnenswerter Zwischenschritt rausgestellt. Also kann ich nur sagen, die sind jetzt mit dem Job und mit dem Skillset, den sie entwickelt haben. Man muss dazu sagen, das waren auch sehr selbstmotivierte Leute. Sie sind hier super zufrieden gewesen. Das kommt halt immer auf den Typen an. Aber das ist jetzt noch so ein Aspekt, den ich finde, dass er relevant ist.
Wie gesagt, Softwareentwickler ist in meinen Augen eine typische FH-Geschichte. Also dass du das, wenn du wirklich programmieren möchtest und Software entwickeln möchtest, ist das eine Sache, wo du typischerweise in meinen Augen eine FH gehörst.
Wie lange dauert das? Genau, wie Uni ist es nur eine andere Ausrichtung?
Es ist dauermäßig genau das Gleiche. Also drei Jahre Bachelor, zwei Jahre Master. Wie gerade schon gesagt, auch mit Möglichkeit zu promovieren. Und viele machen dann im Gegensatz zu einem normalen Hochschulstudium tatsächlich beim Bachelor Schluss. Und das kann auch völlig okay sein. Also das ist tatsächlich dann eher so ein industrieakzeptierter Abschluss.
Apropos industrieakzeptierter Standards, eine Sache, die mir auch auch beantragt. Ich möchte mich beim Chaosradio Team bedanken, weil auf der Suche nach Gästen zu dieser Sendung haben die sich ganz viel Mühe gegeben, auch Gästinnen an den Start zu bekommen, was leider überhaupt nicht geklappt hat, weil die nicht konnten oder wollten. Aber noch mal für die Zuhörerinnen auch, ist diese Besetzung hier 100% männlich, ist das auch das Klischee des Informatikstudiums?
Es werden glücklicherweise immer mehr Frauen, aber es sind immer noch sehr wenige.
Es werden wieder mehr, muss man sagen. Mitte der 80er hat es mal gepiekt bei 40% Anteil und seitdem ist es runtergegangen. Gerade ändert sich das wieder so ein bisschen. Aber es ist tatsächlich nur Maschinenbau schlimmer. Vielschichtige Ursachen. Meines Erachtens daran, dass z.B. in den 80er Jahren Computerspiele hauptsächlich als Jungs-Spielzeug verkauft wurden. Deswegen standen bei den Jungs die Computern rum. Als diese Generation an die Unis gekommen ist, waren das die, die von klein auf schon Computer dastehen zu haben. Deswegen sind sie da reingerutscht. Aber das ist bestimmt auch eine eigene Sendung, das mal zu diskutieren.
Ich kenne solche Phänomene. Ein Ausbildungsleiter, den ich kenne von einem großen ISP, steht immer auf diesem Ausbildungsmessen, wo Schüler und Schülerinnen hingehen, um Dinge zu erfahren über Ausbildungsberufe. Dann kommen dann irgendwelche Schülerinnen zu dem Stand. Plötzlich steht dann die Tante daneben und zieht am Arm weg. Nee, das ist nichts für dich. Und das erlebt er leider immer wieder. Und dass das familiäre Umfeld sagt, mit dieser Technik, das ist nichts für dich, mach doch lieber was, was für Frauen richtig ist.
Dann möchte ich gleich ein bisschen das Mikrofon brechen und an dieser Stelle aber auch aufrufen. Informatikstudium ist eine schreckliche Angelegenheit, das soll aber jeder erfahren dürfen. Und jede vor allen Dingen. Gut, dann vielen Dank Andreas, David, Mutags, Tobias, dass ihr hier wart und uns einen Einblick gegeben habt. Vielen Dank ans Team Mo, Kai und Helena und Danimo. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, ich beschließe dieses Chaosradio 238. Habe nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network.